okay so let's talk random acts of
violence
this project took a long time to get
here oh my god that actually scared me i
thought something scary was about to
happen
i've drawn 1 000 kills once in a while
one of them might match up with
something that happens in this country
we need to call the cops and tell them
what that is a killer running around
recreating murders for my comics
what was it about this project that kept
you motivated and active to bring it to
life
it's been a while yeah it's been running
like
nine years almost to answer your
question it was passion it's a baby it's
a
movie like this only happens if it's
somebody's baby
yeah well you star in it you direct it
you write it
so you can see that passion massive
horror fan
a lifelong fan of the genre i've wanted
to
make horror movies and action movies my
entire life since i was a kid
and this particular one contained a
debate in it and a conversation that i
found
really compelling and i was like haven't
seen
a horror movie about artistic
responsibility in the creative process
i had no place like this to is any of
this uh getting your creative
juices flowing this could be the scene
of a massacre yes
so the characters in this movie are
traveling uh
the i-90 this is a road trip that will
be
really fun and really informative we are
staying
in all motels they're all rural and
they're all real
what would make your ultimate canadian
road trip
oh that's a good that's a very good
question i uh
obviously like any good road trip
getting there in one piece
is the most important thing i think so
what you know literally anything that
isn't the road trip the characters go on
in this movie would be an ideal one
obviously this is an extreme example of
one person's obsession
what kinds of things or collectibles
do you get obsessed with do you have
something
yeah i do it's a constant issue
i was an issue with uh with with my wife
so i'm in the basement this is where
anything i'm interested in
is allowed to be um
but no my my biggest collection in
addition to like
hockey stuff i guess as you can see um
is
i have uh an ever-growing collection of
military antiques
i love i'm with you on hockey so that's
like super dope to me
and i see the lights in the background
that's your man we're in your man cave
right now
that's it that's exactly right with the
montreal flag and the halves and a bunch
of christmas lights
sometimes the wife indulges me uh often
not
uh but uh but yeah so i i that that's
kind of my big passion